these were historic scenes nurses on the
picket line for the first time I'm
a great day and now they will be seen
again after the RCN rejected the
government's payoffer addressing her
members chief executive Pat Cullen said
she has never been prouder but Mark like
many of his Union colleagues wants
answers patcon and the RCN Council have
a lot of hard questions to answer as to
why they recommended this deal in the
first place when
um you know so many of the membership
obviously didn't want it and rejected it
the offer not only rejected but more
strike dates announced for the end of
April with a ballot on further action to
come this offer was not enough for our
members and it is now down to the
government to listen to the voice of
Nursing and put a better offer on the
table they need to restore the nurse's
pay
it's a decision that puts the RCN one of
the largest Health unions in conflict
with another Unison its members voted in
favor if we've got a split decision on
the staff Council then government will
have to look at that and make a balanced
decision about whether they proceed to
implement but if you know if the
majority of health workers are saying
they want to accept the offer then
government could be in a tricky position
the health secretary Steve Barkley says
the Unison result proves the offer is
fair and reasonable calling the rcn's
decision hugely disappointing and
concerning for patients we have two of
the biggest Health unions at odds with
each other with the other health unions
still Consulting with their members
about what to do with the government's
payoffer we're in limbo until the end of
the month when all of the organizations
will go back to the government and
hopefully then there will be some sort
of resolution the Us in will ballot its
members about strike action for the last
six months of this year and that brings
about the prospect of nurses and Junior
doctors standing together on the picket
line for the first time
Mark is ready to strike again but
despite his Union's result he could yet
have a deal he rejected forced on him
Ashish Joshy Sky News